Michelle is with us in New York hi
Michelle how are you hi Dave I am doing
okay I'm a new listener and I it's a
pleasure to talk to you you too oh no
thanks
this is my situation so my husband
passed away just three years ago on the
4th of March and I did not expect I
received a settlement check from the
state he died suddenly and I wanted to
purchase a new home and buy a car so
we're talking about roughly 3/4 of a
million dollars Wow
but just for myself money for the
children is totally separately and we
have some children and they each have
200k apiece I'm told are your kids
Oh 10 and 8 ok so you're going to put
two you you've got 200k in each of their
names for their college and their future
yes and you've got three quarters of a
million 750 thousand no I have I have I
have just a little bit above three I
have three 15:03 hundred and fifty
thousand okay yeah I misunderstood okay
so one less range home were you thinking
of buying
ah good question I wanted to know if to
about two hundred not more than that you
don't pay cash and that leaves you one
hundred and fifty and you're gonna buy a
car for how much ah no more than fifteen
good okay and so that leaves you one
hundred and thirty-five to invest yeah
are you working not at the moment I just
graduated and with a degree in what
company Lipton liberal art what are you
gonna do I'm nursing you're going to
nursing
yes when I took this semester off I'll
be starting back in fall of this year
and how are you paying for that good
question I had a plan on taking someone
the other side to go to private school
for that degree why do you need to go to
a private school for that degree because
I've tried with City College and our
community colleges and it's taking way
longer and much fun around and I thought
what are you living at I love a good
question my husband we are surviving on
his social security survivors benefit so
you're not touching this money you're
eating off of that yes but that
basically eats up everything because
that's direct yeah good good I don't
want you messing with this nest egg and
I want you to go to the least expensive
school that you can as fast as you can
and get your income going because you
don't have much money left after you do
these things join me bills if you pay
cash for a house for 200 and you buy a
car for 15 you don't have a bunch of
money left here it sounds like a lot
because you're not used to having that
much but it'll go away really really
fast if you don't stay on the budget
with that Social Security and you don't
get yourself in an inexpensive nursing
school that money is gonna be gone you
see what I'm saying yes yeah you've been
very wise so far I'm very proud of you
you've done a good job you've taken your
time you've been very diligent yeah a
lot of people would have spent through
this and not lived on that Social
Security benefit and so you've didn't
you've done a really really good job
have you been through Financial Peace
University yet
thank you no let me give that to you I
want you to go through okay so that we
can walk with you and help you on the
details of how to handle your money and
how to manage your money from this point
forward because you've made good
decisions so far I'm very proud of you
but you're you're by yourself and I'm a
Christian and my Bible says take care of
widows so that's what I'm gonna do all
right you hold on and we'll get you
signed up Kelly will give you a free
membership to that you go to
class you've got full access to every
dollar plus online you've got full
access to the communities there you're
gonna get a lot of people loving you and
helping you as you walk through making
all these decisions you take your time
and be very very very careful with this
money you've done a good job so far
don't get out of control
hold on Kelly I'll pick up - we'll help
you out